until I met Nate I'd never had I guess
real real love did Jeffrey star and
Nathan Sh want call it quits wait a
minute
fans are freaking out over the
possibility that the couple has ended
their a five year long relationship
after a series of canceled events and
lack of social posts it's been a minute
it's been a little little while as nay
furries love is seemingly up in the air
ET is taking you inside the couple's
controversial relationship let's take it
back to early 2014 when Nate a
small-town kid from Michigan slid into
Jeffery stars DMS it goes down in the DM
we met on Instagram is that crazy I mean
I don't even think it's crazy because
where do people meet bars clubs things
that we don't do by March 2015
their budding romance was official just
four months after Jeffery launched his
now mega successful makeup brand jeffree
star cosmetics I felt like we had met
for years that we've known each other
for years it was really yes crazy
in March 2016 after a year of dating the
couple released the boyfriend Q&A part
one video where they revealed Nate had
previously only dated women but never
felt the need to label his sexuality
it's not about gender it's more so about
having connection with somebody and
that's just something that clicked with
me Jeffery and Nathan have received a
lot of flack for their relationship over
the years internet trolls and Jeffrey
Stan's alike have often claimed Nate's
only in it for the money
Nathan met me before I had money plain
and simple so please let's move on from
that subject and on top of that they
have the support of mates parents and
brothers it was amazing like everything
was dope they made me feel so at home
comfortable in my own skin like there
was never any weird moment in June 2017
Jeffery addressed some of the negative
comments he was seeing online in a video
titled the truth about my relationship
it's crazy when complete strangers try
to pick apart my relationship and he
even explains it a little that you know
he's always been attracted to guys that
look like women Jeffery bought Nathan's
family a home in Michigan that same year
we have this amazing life but a lot of
you only see us you know reviewing face
masks or you know on trips together
jeffree star cosmetics released the star
family collection in October 2017 which
was designed to represent Nate and
Jeffrey's relationship and therefore
Pomeranian dogs diva diamond delicious
and daddy during an episode of Shane
Dawson's youtube series The Secret World
of Jeffrey star in August 2018 Jeffery
revealed that he and Nate loved having
threesomes but they have rules all jokes
aside never in our embedded only in
other parts of the world or when we're
traveling so we don't have to see them
ever again
the pair has also dealt with a lot of
heartache in their five years together
including losing not one but two of
their beloved Pomeranians most recently
Daddy star and there's been plenty of
drama I feel like the cancel culture I
feel like happened II was the first
person to jumpstart that and she really
tried to cancel me fast-forward to 2019
Nate deleted all of his social media
accounts and in a recent interview with
youtuber and friend Trisha Paytas
Jeffery revealed why people were getting
really too aggressive right every DM is
the oh my god I mean it's like you know
what I don't wanna be online anymore do
you care like I'll be in your videos
obviously like I love you like it's our
family in our lives right he loves you -
he loves filming right he's like I don't
want to like scroll like I don't care
about yeah do we did all of it Jeffery
also told Tricia the pair have surprised
invested in a marijuana company I'm
gonna read us to the ground a lot of
people what does Nate do all day to see
do nothing we invested merit into the
marijuana business in Michigan okay we
don't ever talk about that it makes a
lot of money and it's in his name Wow so
he and he like what obvious passionate
about weed no big site loves weed more
than me but besides that he is doing new
things and today actually was in an
airplane flying over Malibu and he is in
flight Aviation School in January 2020
the couple officially moved out of their
self-proclaimed pink Barbie mansion and
into a 14 million dollar Hidden Hills
chateau Jeffrey told Tricia on her
podcast last month his make up
collaboration with Shane Dawson quote
changed his life and led to the purchase
of the extravagant home I was already
planning on moving right yeah so then
it's just like we weren't gonna move
until next year because conspiracy just
happened and then all of a sudden you
know life happens right the couples last
post together was January 1st with a
tour of their brand-new house fans
started speculating and there was major
trouble in paradise
just days after the tour was uploaded
when the beauty mogul canceled his
planned masterclass tour in the UK with
fellow influencer and makeup artist
mamama Mitchell Mitchell took to
Instagram to address the change of plans
claiming the cancellation is due to
unforeseen circumstances that really
can't be helped but what really sent
fans over the edge was when they
realized Geoffrey deleted wifey of
Nathan from his Instagram bio Jeffery
has yet to comment on the situation
stick with ET for updates
[Music]